happy aliens Sam here with our JD Neiman
hey what's up where do you work and what
do you do I work at Conan and I work at
Kona Co great that's enough yeah welcome
everyone happy aliens day I've got my
best orgy of the Dead shirt on because
that's what today is an orgy of the Dead
we're gonna be dying a lot we're playing
the end of alien isolation look I don't
like to use my position here at the show
at Team Coco for personal gain but I've
been playing alien isolation quite a bit
and we're kind of in the final run and
look I just want to keep playing it and
so I'm doing it at work question is it
aliens like happy aliens day like the
movie are all aliens everywhere
two things one you're not allowed to ask
questions number two it's aliens the
movie dude like James Cameron come on
it's actually more like the first one
really Scott hello death by fugu
good to see you read by nature porkchop
Reis Kim a rim RAAM RAAM RAAM I love
that Rimmer and we're gonna have some
room RAM today Ozzy the Aussie you know
exactly okay so what's happening is you
guys in the corner good happy alien day
happy alien day happy alien day
emergency
all right just okay so let me back up to
fill in RJ and whoever else has not
played alien isolation you play Ripley's
daughter Ripley you know Sigourney
Weaver and this takes place I believe
between alien and aliens so what happens
is at the end of alien spoiler alert and
go go see the movie go see the movie but
I'm gonna ruin the end
Ripley kind of ends up in a ship that
ends up in space and no one knows where
she is yet in aliens they find her and
then she's rescued and then they send
her back into the pits of hell but this
is that that place between Leroy
Jennings I don't know if we're gonna do
Resident Evil 7 we did Resident Evil 6
for clueless gamer actually tomorrow
night I believe O'Malley Wright is gonna
be a new clueless gamer make sure to
watch Conan in VR he's terrible so I did
we are to be fair it's super hard okay
no one cares good so basically this is
the between alien and I am so sorry
between
aliens and your Ripley's daughter you're
on a space station yeah and there's some
[ __ ] that's going on a space station you
find out there's a xenomorph who I like
to call Gary you fight Gary I don't know
what is xenomorph is it's a it's the
alien oh and and you get rid of the
alien then you have to fight a bunch of
robots and try to get off the station
but then you find there's actually a
whole host of aliens on the station now
they're in their nest in the reactor
core you flush the reactor core which is
what we just did and now we've sent
instead of killing the aliens we've sent
the aliens all over the space station so
now we have to get back to Ricardo and
then try to escape with Ricardo while
avoiding aliens that's where we're at
it's the end of this hug off [ __ ] ha Ken
says love this game gave me such
nostalgic capture the feel of the alien
ship perfectly I agree and I was just
telling RJ like the art direction in
this game is absolutely unbelievable
it's so cool so I'll play a little bit
just to flirting Spurgin it is RJ ah
that's me yeah this is RJ right here
any sneak picking the new clueless gamer
termi says no sneak peek but I'll show
you in a little while some some pictures
on my phone how about that what's the
name of the game you play includes K
Wilson's heart an oculus rift aliens
name is Alan is that true gig giggling
alright so I don't know we're gonna go
so we haven't got a gun oh that's cool
we also have a host of other things we
got a bolt gun which is dope what is
this PlayStation Nintendo PlayStation
it's a PlayStation dude Jesus get your
[ __ ] together we got a Molotov which
looks cool okay we got although it's a
waste of good alcohol EMP mine smoke
bomb noisemaker this is what we're
working with we also have a shotgun but
right now we're gonna keep the
flamethrower because it's the only thing
that kind of scares things and we have
this little baby scary cool this is what
tells us that there's aliens around also
tells us where to go like the
Ghostbusters thing it's not at all like
the Ghostbusters it no it doesn't sense
ghosts no it's not thing that's not know
that sense is the paranormal
sorry Nancy Oh giggle and says that's
the name
alien hasn't all the debug texts and
things I was QA on the game whoa you
could find my name with some the water
posters that's awesome holy [ __ ] well if
we come to a wanted poster with your
name on it I want to see your face
giggity-giggity giggling yeah Oh Alan
that's really cool wow that's a nice
little tidbit there alright so Alan then
all right here we go we skim the
graphics are amazing I agree they are
and great job by the way
well well done giggling giggling
giggling giggling giggling alright so
we've got to make it oh so we're looking
around here go to the st. Cristobal
medical facility get to the engineering
so you're on a spaceship right we're on
a space station yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
turn up alright and this game is freaky
alright so let's get into the kids so we
want to go to the what do you want to go
engineering transit station so this is
where we came from I believe yeah
alright engineering transit station ok
ok so you just have to go over here
right call the transit this game is so
free so when I die which is gonna be
quickly yeah I'm gonna give it to you
say this is how we play you got the
sticks here left trigger brings up the
gun hooray trigger fires circle lets you
choose things this is very handy right
stick in crouches and this is like you
sneaking around using an axe kind of
like lets you hide under desks
a very nervous right now where's this so
there's only one other alien on this now
there's ik now there's more than there
was one but we flush the reactor core
like idiots I think we want to go this
way right
yeah looks like a subway wait we don't
want to go to the Lorenz cystic spire
Dewey we're trying to get to the
engineering transit station that's where
we are yeah trying to get the medical
facility we don't want to go here
hey Tunisia hey noob noob fruit love you
too
hello guys come and join my livestream
okay whatever alright here we go Kevin
yo is so great Kevin Nealon is the best
by the way we are Jay and I interview
Kevin he did well
he's awesome but it was a little weird
because RJ and I get nervous and Kevin
Nealon is obviously the man you know I
grew up like on 90s SNL he was super
nice but he came he sat in the podcast
with all of his people all like like
eight people like eight people came it
usually it's just us and I guess Magana
takes like two minutes and everybody's
comfortable yeah it was just it was an
audience or more like the most will be
like brie Larson when we interview
Larson also amazing human being a great
person she just brought like her manager
a Jenner right that's fine yeah and they
were there and it's great but Kevin
Nealon just like hands like extended
family
yeah he was doing bits which is great
and he was killing the energy like I
love you this is Simon tower we want to
go to again medical station right maybe
that's the way if anybody's played this
by the way let us feel yes tell us hey
you rocks with a red sign Med tower
maybe this is the witness this the way
we want to go
Isaac Marquez scary music it is kind of
freaky music it's pretty cute it was on
in here the whole time before we went
live or whatever Zac's freaking me out
I say we go director : play so that's
off line the only one we haven't opened
up is this one so let's try this one
what
oh that reminds me movie doesn't have
come down I guess the sign I think the
sign meant ours everybody go I'm gonna
how many go let's go this way alright
you please keep with occulus really holy
crap Oh science medical Thank You
Florence burger check the map on where
to go turn off the lights
Oh should we turn off the lights yeah
let's do it let's turn down these lights
a little bit
sorry Oh mouse thanks somali mm-hmm
turn off these lights
let's get creepy oh yeah you don't have
to look at her oh yeah they keep turning
them down keep turning the other one
down a little bit
oh yeah oh there we go this is nice and
creepy oh I like this a lot
yeah oh this is great oh I'm nervous all
right here we go
why'd you send me here you dick so we're
trying to get to another ship ambulance
Bay oh man got a safe got a safe I'll
just save you
yeah is it great that's awesome school
is that let's get cozy needless audio
echo uh uh rule number one don't run
rule number two
rule number two so you can hide in
lockers see the things you hold to hide
now I see you're laughing it sounds like
high school also yeah okay Adam and then
you can lean back and then l2 I think it
lets you you hold your breath alright
just rule number one don't run and he's
right
never run alright where do you want to
go here this also kind of show if you do
this it shows you kind of where to go
like a man yes you see that thing on the
edge there how it's moving around that
shows you where to go see what I'm
talking about yes yes on the top yeah
very nervous so that's our motion
detector base of it
what are these specs is it just like
dusty in here what's happening yeah dude
it's a it's a district it's just the air
okay sirs where is this oh there's
something behind us it's so scary game
is so scary
he plays alone in your house yeah
there's definitely something behind us
home I'm actually this game I hate
releasing right next to the TV
this keeps much I hate this game so much
so it doesn't show you where the alien
is no dude well sometimes if it's moving
if there's movement it will show you is
the point to get off this thing yeah
point is we're trying to get off the
ship
we're training off the shoe
don't I want to go this way Oh God Oh
God don't worry aren't you scared
peace Barsky thanks for setting about
does it tell you our Paul Reiser is no
by the way I washed I've been watching
there's this great made by a documentary
of how they made aliens not alien to
alien so James Cameron okay it's on
YouTube it's really great it's super
long it's awesome and actually says that
Paul Reiser there was a scene that gets
cut with Paul Reiser and when Sigourney
Weaver's going in at the end of kill the
alien queen oh this looks good oh this
looks good oh he's that's Ricardo he's
helping us he polarisers all like in the
nest or whatever he's a kill me and he's
gonna have a chest burster that Ripley
like gives him a grenade just puts a
grenade in his hand and then leaves and
he blows himself up this is
this is really cool it's awesome alright
here we go oh that guy there's a dude I
don't even see him
oh yeah died dude Klaus [ __ ] there's
something behind us bonfires are always
safe
you're right stranger 59 what are you
doing maybe we should make something as
long as we can med kit no can we make
mod that dude is dead you pee mine no
noisemaker maybe smoke bomb maybe
something's going on
Sean loafer bonfires in space yeah it
doesn't make the most sense what is that
I'm gonna make a quick just so I can
when I max stuff out I like to just be
able to make more stuff noisemaker will
the aliens God the aliens go for the
aliens go for noise
I'm nervous man
yeah me too we got to go this way can
you climb up there no no we're going the
way this thing is telling us to go this
smokey duff stuff is not helping I think
it's just smoke so I say nope it doesn't
say all like savor it's nice its hey
it'll help us make a medkit Molotov take
this [ __ ] how do I make him all the time
Oh any compound be alright sorry alright
molest the alien what the chest we just
you can't molest the alien kids Oh God
nervous is this cool they look how great
this game looks it's amazing a lot of
things to hide under in here that's all
I'm saying
where is this alien don't we don't want
the alien you know we don't want to see
the alien aliens very scary
also the alien can hear like whenever we
owe
oh there's a dude oh Jesus walking do my
[ __ ] wait why is that bad because he'll
kill us a human no no no oh dude what
are you do getting under the thing to
hide oh my god
fact that you were actually in the
Andrus so imagine an Android dude it's
an Android see he's coming close oh my
God he's gonna see us
oh no no he doesn't know we're here he
doesn't over here oh no he does it does
he yeah he's kicking us alright get him
alright hold on how do I get it I guess
how about the flame throughout I don't
know the bulk guns gonna do it oh my god
oh my - our job we're great
don't blow a hole in the spaceship got
him in the Hat get it good guys because
he's wearing like a suit what oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] he saw us for sure I don't
know Jillian I don't know I don't think
he saw the alien for sure saws [ __ ] you
have to run away dude we can try he sees
us he's gonna kill us he sees this he's
gonna kill us he saw oh god my get
another thing oh we're dead we're dead
we're always looking under the other one
oh my god this is horrifying this is
horrifying
oh he's gonna see no he's not shut up
shut up shut up shut up shut up please
shut up grabs tail Graham is still where
do you go oh oh we're dead we're dead
he's gonna look under here
[Music]
okay we're okay man everything's fine
Dix everything's fine everything's fine
man everything's fine everything's
totally he deaf he didn't you didn't see
this man we're dead well daddy sauce
also why I hate this game I hate this
game I hate this game I hate this honor
RJ you gotta be stop being so negative
I'm so sorry
well you what just happen for you to
blow great this the last five seconds
guys I don't even know how to play these
games god I hate this game how do i duck
that's the key I feel alright so pushing
in the right stick yeah ducks and also
to get under stuff you press X and this
stick no no no you just press X but like
to get under to get under like the table
you need to put you need to be ducking
and then press X yeah so why not leave
we look the other way my dev I didn't
have a chance to leave so I think you
want to pull out a press r1 oh just hold
it so that yeah there you go forgot that
see where that bar is in the time okay
oops I crapped my pants to do it worth
God repelled him with fire oh yeah
you're right I totally forgot we had the
can I give this yeah at that now
remember there's a there's an Android
around the corner here that's right I
totally forgot we had to flame through
it we should have just torched him it's
a shame you just can't kill the alien
Explorer peacefully I agree milk well
something happened on here I heard
something yeah cuz there's something
press r1 there's a something around the
corner it's the it's kinda troy'd no how
do I pull out my flamethrower or my L to
press and hold l2 but the flamethrowers
not gonna kill you with this
yeah but the flavor is not gonna kill
the the Android droid what you want to
do is hold o and switch to the bolt gun
I took a wheel yeah there you go yeah go
to the bolt gun just look the box oh
right just pressed up into the right
dude there you go let it go let it go
all right now with the bolt gun you have
to press and hold the left trigger and
then press and hold the right trigger no
charges up and then let the right
trigger go and it's like charge though
it's hard man and you gotta aim for
their head but also I think we can just
sneak around this dude I don't know that
you need it I think we can sneak around
I don't really you need to kill this guy
oh you gotta go to the left
I think they should update the alien
scene of the Hollywood Studios ride to
this scary I agree Ozzy the Aussies
clenched all the time dude I am clenched
100% right now got a strong clench going
right now I sure daily we're like you hi
don't fight this Jamie oh dude don't you
gotta hit him in there
[ __ ] up really yeah he's still there
again yes but it takes a while to charge
up shoot him in the head do you oh god
oh my god oh I told you this cake was
horrifying that would be attracting the
alien by shooting Jesus oh my god
all right here oh I don't want to run I
hate this I hate this game so much I
hate this game I hate it I hate this
game but I love it just walk past the
Android with the flame thrower flare
again split again says walk past the
Android with the flamethrower what do
you mean no like so it's ready you know
what I mean
cuz the alien will come out and then
just get the alien right oh yeah yeah I
think we did it right before hardest
part of this game is that menu okay
so do we think the aliens gonna come out
here what do we think yeah for sure but
after you see the dude but I still want
to I need to go past that guy right
alien that must mean that much in his
way yeah did he come out do we see him
is he out Oh God oh is he down there I
don't see him I think he's up we only
tracked him by shooting before yeah read
by nature I'd love to see Neill
Blomkamp's pitch okay so I'm in the
locker can you do that it's art dude
yeah we can't oh yeah you already did
there's our dude right there he's just
staring yeah he hasn't seen us yet he's
he gonna turn around we're on to make
sure that aliens not there he's not dude
because the thing oh he picked oh [ __ ] I
think he is coming behind us this is so
scary that comes out yeah you're right
monkeys on tree he comes out from the
bolt guns noise but I don't know that
but warble warble orful I think we have
to we have to get by this guy we have to
shoot the bolt gun right hiding the
locker also makes noise wait are you
sure the flamethrower doesn't kill this
guy too
no flame throws don't do then he can be
ready all right here's what I think our
plan is I think we lure the guy out will
the alien kill that guy no go into the
room on the left
try running and have the flamethrower
ready for the alien use a distraction
okay you do that oh that's a good idea I
like that idea a lot okay wait so here's
what we're in a good idea Malcom okay so
what we're gonna do is if he's near the
locker you hold your breath
yeah there's so much blood yeah all
right wonder if we could throw let's try
this let's try a little noisemaker over
there okay get the deed to turn around
right okay actually before we do that
oh he's oh he saw us we're [ __ ]
we're not [ __ ] but I think what we
have to do here's what I think we have
to do I think I'm gonna switch the
bolt-gun kill him kill him at the
bolt-gun oh the aliens gonna come yeah
yeah but we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna torch his ass okay now you gotta
run away no oh oh oh I see what you're
doing oh you can hear him in the vents
come on baby let's go let's go bring it
outside here can you hold your breath I
don't know that thing's gonna make noise
and light yeah but it's okay I think we
I think we did it hiding the locky
resolved your issues with it talk to it
up for the alien of Pepsi our noku who
plays this game anymore it's aliens day
by aliens day get your [ __ ] together
come on man Jesus Oh is there another
aliens game you'd rather see I'm sorry
maybe every day is aliens day for that
guy and really get me started
show some respect what are you what did
you just do I gave myself some extra
help all right here's what we're gonna
do dude we're just gonna push forward
with the flamethrower which is a
terrible idea
Oh God hmm just we'll be fine
there's a living room I would never sit
in that looks really uncomfortable
everything's fine
everybody's good everything's fine we're
all good
look how good we are look at how good
and totally fine we are uh oh good and
totally fine coming up on the scanner
yeah I know
swinging me really nervous all right by
the way the lighting in this game is
absolutely phenomenal is really good
where are we where'd you hear something
yeah it's that thing blowing up Otis you
sure no that sounds like something
around where is it where is it where is
it there it is get away Oh screw you
oh now you just pissed it off and I know
dudes not dead alone charge bag with God
I'm getting under the table you can't
stop me
big Bucky boy all you need is a predator
and your problems will be solved no
kidding sure oh my god dude we're almost
out of flamethrower oh Jesus
Oh God oh no I hear it I hear it and now
it knows to look under tables I'm very
unhappy okay you get the flamethrower
out is he on top of your bed I don't
know where is it oh it's behind us I
think we just got to go
can I call the police not in space you
guys are dead
oh he's closed doors closed he's closed
he's closed oh there is there yes there
he is oh I hate this game so much
that'll attract so much oh don't look
over here don't look over he's got it
got him got him oh we're out of [ __ ] God
god that's so scary that is so scary
your turn fortune favours the ball I can
be some thankless work yes nice ass
alien flame is ass I flamed it so wait
now he doesn't he doesn't whether we
have to do the whole Android thing again
Oh show me to do that part no you can do
it Isaac Marquez I jumped yeah me too
pooped my pants a little
you need [ __ ] you need firepower use all
your weapons hi marshals aha oh thank
you RJ just sprint all the way Chrissy
bro can do that
what wex sorry shoot him in the head
with the with the bolt gun does that
work Nicole Billy has nice teeth
how many levels are in the game that's
it
I don't know oh I think we're very close
to the end how long we been playing this
game like like months but I've only been
playing it on my own twitch channel like
every week all right go left well so
that's why it's taking so long I haven't
played like a lot in here
my dude my god are only curved mouths no
administrative professional would have
killed you on the journey look how
celebrating the wrong day now the wrong
way thank you
oh you went back into the elevator press
I thought you meant press the button I'm
sorry no no no eighteen level says
David's here only flames will scare it
Alex but last time flames didn't scare
it I don't know man months AKA sits like
august 2015 that's true Marshall the
game doesn't like it sir yes you telling
conserve ammo is there particular part
we're in a small room and you need the
flamethrower that part you should be
able to sneak past okay I get you
present I do you have an EMP but the EMP
doesn't it hurt the alien you want to go
back dude we just came from here in this
store yeah there hit that I'll kill you
I'll kill you
it gets amusing
you can't kill it that it'll keep coming
back we keep flaming it I don't know
neues 7 I think we're playing on ps4
except for the new movie yeah what's
this game have any scripted jump scares
I think there's like there's a couple
cutscenes but they're I mean they're
scary but the jump scares all come from
me being dumb Jodi the Red Sox doing
just fine alright mmm-hmm just relax
pie pots Molotov cocktails causal force
away okay okay giggling so maybe we try
some molotovs here all right let's go go
straight get out of here go straight go
left
oh boy somebody there's a shotgun work I
don't know I don't think it does I think
it just pisses it off 360 noscope
alright dude get that [ __ ] you just
missed the [ __ ] yeah get that first
time I saw the alien I cried it's very
scary
you missed a sign injector two on them
tail but it doesn't matter you're gonna
die get out of here I'm gonna beat the
game right now
fingers crossed a new movie isn't
disappointing like Prometheus I agree I
really like the look of Prometheus I
thought it looked very me too but I did
not enjoy so much
hey that PSC sucks thank you very much
it's funny I saw a demon Lindelof a lot
right after Prometheus came out at the
wp Starbucks really did you we saw them
a couple times oh yeah yeah yeah I
wanted that oh so maybe you can run what
maybe you could hide from this dude
under here don't you know he's gonna see
you he's gonna see you go under there
but like see if you can walk away see if
you can yeah see if you can kind of pull
him into the other fire area going to
the other fire area where you just came
from take a right is this the way you
came from yeah so you think I'm pulling
back in that area and then hide you
don't have saying so you can just keep
walking forward I think that's the way
to do it
which way'd you come from where do you
go
he's behind you dude I don't know which
way did you go would you would you go
Scooby right here oh oh yeah just
kicking around the boxes how's this guy
gonna kill me by the way no he just
beats you to death oh we're gonna keep
going keep going
oh [ __ ] I can't get you oh yeah go go
this way and I'm saying like goat it go
this way go around the thing make him
follow you cuz he's so slow stay in this
room but just go around the thing and
then you know what I'm saying keep
walking you know what to say yeah maybe
he'll hit fire is that you're saying no
I'm saying he just takes so long to walk
that we could just keep walking past him
and just go keep going cuz we're so that
way okay yeah we can Juke him
you know a classic Juke classic you hi
I'm gonna do you right yeah just go so
just go oh clap can't believe you've
done this as coffee kills classic cubed
ooh what a classic Jeep that was a
classic Juke but also wheezy a lien
around here somewhere
we didn't wait you hear the alien
okay keep going keep going alright keep
going we didn't so you wanna go straight
and then to the left
why is everything I don't know man
because the ship's about to blow up I
don't know what that is that really
scared me Oh scary like a smoke monster
from lost speaking of David learn a lot
okay keep going keep going
doing good you're doing really good
doing great
doing really great why is this low great
question I don't know cuz we don't want
to run because that attracts the alien
does it it does we know that for a fact
if you run you're gonna die I'll kidding
like Twinkletoes it I think you want to
take a left here but check it check your
thing oh yeah ambulance Bay this is the
right way
no no that way I think press r1 I think
this is the right way keep going keep
going
I think this is the right way hit the
can I hit this real quick yeah yeah this
is good find an ambulance craft in the
medical Bay so we got to find an
ambulance craft here so let's look
around wait we might turn to left what's
that yeah what is that
[Music]
nice there we go upgrade that's
something we need okay good okay try it
taking a left yeah here we go here we go
baby back the door board the shuttle
let's do it okay so uh press X wherever
you can thank you and then it might be
like a puzzle wait turn is that don't
what's the dude over there maybe yeah
maybe
why do I owe a flashbang okay I'm
feeling isolated here we go here we go
all right so here so tune into the cyst
so basically with the left stick you
want to go around until a screen appears
okay
and then when the right stick you're
only gonna have a certain amount of time
to pick the right stick you want to
select what what symbols they are and
hit X so like bottom left hit X yeah and
then the next one is whatever top right
oh yeah yeah so you got to do that here
you do this I don't know what I'm even
pressing okay
I mean it's cool so see it's this this
this yes fine hell no wait sorry it's
hard man
okay artists it's this this this this
yes yes yes get in there get in there
boy
there you go I don't play them well yes
I do play games right now I'm playing
the witness which is super fun wait down
on the ground dude down on the ground oh
we don't need it okay sorry Lots watch
wants to shuttle get out of here let's
get the hell off this station yes oh
here we go baby here we go baby there's
no way we're not gonna have to fight
some crazy alien I'm scared right now if
this turns into a flying game would be
so happy sad Vega I think it's I think
it's both you and the alien are both
isolated
I hope the aliens waving it yes to suka
sook my channels just twitch.tv slash
Erin Blair yeah I'm gonna play outlast 2
at some point for sure your chosen kappa
alien a baby
happy alien day don't get your hopes up
you'll be back in the station soon
enough I love it
I do like again I love like the VHS
footage this game is awesome happy alien
day everybody you're just joining us
with our JD Neiman hey guys and tomorrow
new clueless gamer Kona plays oculus
rift he's a really bad at it yeah you're
right if it's too good to be true it
usually is in life as well as this game
now we're are we just on this a little
ship
it's okay Ricardo you suck
we're Carter's just leaving us out here
dude to [ __ ] fight these aliens
oh it save your game they'll go straight
go straight to that so many times like
so the save points always beep like that
oh that's ok you're fine
and so many times I've spent like trying
to find the dumb save point yes yes I'm
drinking a natty light that's right beer
at work everyone
gotta love the save baby Ricardo's not
awesome Sarver sauce mean one thing
Ricardo's done for us part of sucks
karna blows fu Ricardo good all these
papers weird hashtag Ricardo sup oh I
totally thought that was an alien you
can't tell me they didn't make those two
look like two aliens I know what this is
look at him what are they doing
something it looks like we're gonna have
to turn that I don't know can you maybe
Matt Cardle blue isn't something Ricardo
open the door for us we're trapped yet
didn't help us any other way
he's just sitting pretty in the van I'll
be in the van guys good luck says
Ricardo I don't know andreas wolf alien
day is a thing that I only hope that
they've started oh yeah feeling lucky
for 36 seconds what does that mean it's
playing the audio message a little flaw
Nostromo dark I found the Nostromo you
can hit that
great the Nostromo
oh yeah use that thing we've got some
flares in there oh I do like me some
flares grab that [ __ ] yo
Oh Flint's our fuel even better perfect
good Oh alien days because the planet is
lv-426 is where they find the alien
today's 426 ah 6 thank you Mary otter
also Big Oil's birthday Marlo wait what
is this signal could be Nostromo
[ __ ] we don't want to go to the
Nostromo ok leave Alan alone he's just a
lost give you space squirrel ask her
required we don't have it oh you know
what go back into the computer this
computer yeah we got to find the
passcode in here anyone who want
prometheus isolation that's funny go to
technicians report X thanks and now go
down 1024 a 45 10 is what it is worried
about 10 okay why would anyone star
flame 4 if you're in the loo where do
you put your flamethrower yeah
45:10 frickin kills something mister
doctor I mean I would love to kill stuff
but it's been killing us unfortunately I
know prey looks awesome my dev I've got
it on pre-order yeah I've been playing
the witness which is really fun and it's
like you guys ever do that thing where
when you're learning something really
hard you're kind of learning a new skill
you can feel your brain hurt or is that
just me like you're you feel your brain
bleed anyway that's what's going on with
the witness and me you can't go through
there okay turn right go go back go Oh
what is this turn to the right restart
it baby
the whole generator that's
like a bad idea click tap X but the
whole ships gonna he's praying is pray
gonna suck it's pretty gonna be great
you guys
ah the witness jamie is a game by the
guy who made braids which is one of my
favorite games of all time and it's
basically I don't know I just started
it's like a lot of like mazes and
puzzles oh go to the other thing you
that's a lot of mazes and puzzles it's
pretty cool but it's like it squad
teaches you like how to do these
different puzzles it's pretty awesome so
far like I said braid if you haven't
played braid what are you doing with
your life go play it it's one of the
greatest games of all time never heard
of it breeds amazing really bad Tekken 7
like still feelings are coming oh yeah
you go through that door you go through
that door now we get out of there
Shengo you that's you can't the lights
are on
well the aliens not on this shock okay
oh where do we go go back in their room
is there anywhere else to get oh here
this thing the middle the middle section
no no turn it yeah right there oh we got
it here I'll do this security access
tuna Oh what is this oh I like all the
little puzzles and stuff it makes this
fun
it's cool
yeah it's a cool there's a really crazy
level where all the working Joe's are
trying to chase you and you have to do
with this all this stuff all the things
play out Tekken 7 is VR compatibility no
way
let the rave party begin baby startup
that Porter Robinson Oprah me this
wasn't necessarily the worst does this
not here ya go huh
amazing it was it was just I think it
just didn't meet expectations but I I
liked a lot of them there were some
really fun parts it just kind of all
didn't congeal and injure Salva is like
the man Michael Fassbender was amazing
Marlo Marlo I'm gonna murder you
yeah don't be a dick Marley hold your
hold hold r1 to r1 button yes it go to
the right Marlo I feel like you're a
prick oh yes oh yeah we got a
flamethrower those chest anything I just
saw my chest Bursar's I'm so scared
it's horrifying lunar it's a good game
here we go oh I got to do that again all
right
there's no alien other ship though right
let's do it
let's go shall investor really watch him
from sim Bob lay that's pretty cool yeah
also is it 45:10 yeah oh god I gonna
need to go see the passcode in here
that's boring
great 45:10 it is Norway what's up
Norway what do you guys want to see from
the new alien movie like what would what
would what would meet expectations in
the Emilia movie scene the xenomorph No
yeah what do you want to see Fred I
haven't seen the newest trailer I've
only seen the very first time anything I
only saw the first one so yeah I feel
like now they've like ramped up it's
like such a crazy degree yeah well I'm
gonna save my game no I can't kiss see
my game god damn it I got to do this
thing first
[Music]
Jamie Henrickson wants to see a good
plot line oh yeah I mean that's honestly
is what made the first two Alien movies
grana they're almost like the plot you
care about the characters you care about
Sigourney Weaver you know more as a
threat to the printer and you're the
prey there you go
no real threat to him so why gotta get
those reflexes baby I want to see them
eat cats like Alf fair enough
I mean I did I guess ask yeah but that
was guys in rubber suits flopping at
each other hey Jack day what's up were
the engineers would be cool Danny
McBride in a tank top I was just
watching by the way if you haven't seen
the foot fist way it's kind of how Danny
McBride got famous the foot this way is
amazing because Will Ferrell and Adam
McKay saw the foot fist way and it's
Danny McBride as a like shitty like a
shitty karate instructor it's really
funny yeah all right where's the save
point isn't he here somewhere
who is directing the new alien movie
really Scott oh oh and I'm not going in
there yeah maybe you want to join my
crew with all my chest besties Sigourney
Weaver gonna be the Navy yeah this is
why I was before right
see the old gamer ooh right here you
know I don't expect puppeteering I wish
I wish that they would stop doing so
much CGI I really like the puppeteering
it just it holds up better man all right
see where we going here
all right to the right to the right to
the left okay here we go
let's flamethrower sand is this gonna
work
watch out for the boxes he's right
behind those boxes yeah Oh God oh just a
quick DoubleTap
does the do they show up for the motion
tracker they must right I don't know
there's a lot of crap in here looks like
my bedroom oh god this is nasty I hate
those things man
what's that does that do anything there
you go
whether you can get killed when you're
at one of these tournaments Oh God
Winona Winona Ryder was in Android
whatever it was that attached itself to
Foster's dead I found on the floor by
the bed I'll curl up like a spider
she felt fine but I put in a hyper split
asleep Oh see that's how that's how it
got onto the ship because uh
Foster said she fell fine she put got it
put her into hypersleep with a chest
burster inside of her wait tom waits out
i hear scary music which is never a good
thing I hate using the flashlight
everyone knows how much I hate the
flashlight because it just makes you a
target
don't use flashlights oh god this is
thank you
fuzzy Oh God
was this game over man came over very
nervous alien through facehuggers yes I
agree Marlo I agree okay but I'm cool
right what's that noise we're cool right
Mauro bro Jesus Christ
cool right Marlo right doc oh she ate
what is that
I gotta go soon all right all right kids
we're almost done here I have to but I
really don't want to leave this is let's
just get inside one Isaac there's music
musics bad one of those deep sleeper you
know what I think we're coming to a safe
point here we go yeah buddy
okay I'm gonna save right here
we didn't walk then and wash their hands
with soap and water so they got infected
all right
oh this is power core shit's gonna go
down in here kids we got to stop it's
one o'clock
thanks for hanging out we have to stop
kneeling is on the ship fair enough
Oh guys happy alien day we have to stop
today I'm sorry show today we're very
excited who's on the show today uh who's
on the show I actually does anybody know
any of God's no ah but tomorrow new
clueless gamer make sure to check that
out who's on the show is it all right
that's great
make sure to watch the show tomorrow
night and tonight obviously but tomorrow
we will have a new clues gamer for y'all
and with Conan playing oculus which is
great and he's terrible at it of course
Dennis Quaid oh yeah yes miss Barham
from Deadpool obviously where my thumb
already Highmore in what and the big
series that's right
happy ailing day everybody happy today
that's right we will see you guys never
going to Wednesday's now so we'll see on
Wednesday next week and don't let the
facehugger get you
you